herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben am
gestrigen tag die kraft und die größe
gehabt eine entscheidung zu revidieren
dafür ist ihnen respekt gezollt worden
die rücknahme der entscheidung zur oster
ruhe war richtig wegen der fragen der
technisch rechtlichen umsetzung wegen
der mangelnden akzeptanz dieser maßnahme
in der bevölkerung allerdings auch die
krisen politik darf sich nicht von der
lebenswirklichkeit der menschen
entfernen wir wissen dass wenn man eine
schraube an zieht immer weiter anzieht
nach fest kommt ganz locker wir sind
darauf angewiesen dass die menschen die
regeln verstehen für logisch und
verhältnismäßig halten und sie deshalb
auch aus eigener entscheidung gefolgt
vor allen dingen hat sich bei der frage
der oster ruhe aber auch die frage der
epidemiologischen notwendigkeit gestellt
ob es tatsächlich eine wirksame
entscheidung ist da haben sie selbst ja
zweifel angemeldet
und deshalb war es richtig diese
entscheidung für die oster ruhe
zurückzunehmen freiheits eingriffe
sollte es nur dort geben wo sie wirklich
notwendig sind und bei allen
gesundheitlichen risiken müssen wir die
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen folgen der
pandemie politik auch stärker
berücksichtigen
sie haben frau bundeskanzlerin für die
entscheidung zur ruhe die verantwortung
auf sich genommen
das ist honorig aber das bringt in der
sache uns nicht weiter auch andere
tragen dafür mitverantwortung
auch die persönlichkeit mit den größten
gaben kann nicht auf dauer alleine die
last der verantwortung tragen das müssen
andere mehr machen nicht nur die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
wenn ich höre in den letzten tagen
welche kritik auch öffentlich aus den
reihen der unions fraktion an ihm
geäußert worden ist wenn ich wenn ich in
erinnerung rufe wie ihr
koalitionspartner spd bisweilen so
auftritt als habe er mit der regierung
gar nichts mehr zu tun
dann stellt sich auch hier die frage der
gemeinsam getragenen verantwortungen
übrigens in wahrsow mein gestriger
hinweis auf die option der
vertrauensfrage zu verstehen
sie erlaubt ja eine neue konzept ua lisi
hrung von politik und ist die
möglichkeit wieder disziplin her zu
stellen
ich habe keinen zweifel dass sich ihre
koalition hinter ihnen versammeln würde
die grünen haben sie sowieso auf ihrer
seite die oster ruhe und die
entscheidung die debatte darüber dürften
dessen aber auch ein licht auf das
verfahren des krisenmanagements ja
vielleicht muss man sogar mehr sagen auf
die staatspraxis der vergangenen jahre
showdown situationen in koalitions-
ausschüssen mit nächtlichen sitzungen
und spontanen entscheidungen dieser
entscheidungs modus kollege mützenich
führt auch dazu dass zum beispiel
landesregierungen und geht sie tragenden
koalition gar nicht einbezogen werden
können ihre ministerpräsidentin malu
dreyer hat zb hat bei der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
unterrichtung des ministerrates nachts
wo grüne und fdp informiert werden
sollten zum beispiel abgesagt wenn wir
ein anderes verfahren wählen komme
gleich darauf zurück dann wäre das
besser
möglich dieses verfahren das bislang
gewährt wird führt systematisch zur
falschen abwägungen
ich rufe aus der jüngsten vergangenheit
nur beispielsweise die plötzlich
erfundene senkung der mehrwertsteuer in
erinnerung die in der sache nichts
gebracht hat und sie heute auch niemand
vermisst es ist fraglich ob die
erfahrene welt politikerin merkel in den
vergangenen jahren nicht zu viel von der
internationalen gipfel diplomatie in
unseren nationalen kontexte gebracht hat
als der sache hier hilft es ist jetzt
deshalb meine damen und herren anlass
und gelegenheit für einen doppelten
neustarts der pandemie politik ein
neustart zunächst im verfahren die
evolution der regierungsformen hat eine
antwort gefunden
auf die zunehmende komplexität der
entscheidungs gegenstände von politik
die antwort heißt parlamentarische
demokratie
wir sollten mehr von parlamentarischer
demokratie wieder in unserer republik
praktizieren
konkret schlage ich vor frau
bundeskanzlerin dass sie vor jeder
ministerpräsidenten konferenz eine
regierungserklärung in diesem haus
abgeben um die grundlinien ihrer
pandemie politik zu erläutern und dann
in diesem parlament darüber eine debatte
zu ermöglichen
das führt systematisch dazu dass
entscheidungen kritisch abgeklopft
werden
und ich bitte sie das jetzt gar nicht
nur auf die fraktion der freien
demokraten auch der kollege
fraktionsvorsitzender der union erbringt
haus hat ja regelmäßig in den debatten
vorschläge unterbreitet die zu oft dann
aber folgenlos geblieben sind debatte
ist ein instrument der
qualitätssicherung hier im parlament und
deshalb sollten wir das systematisch
wieder nutzen
im übrigen bei dieser gelegenheit will
ich gleich sagen
dankenswerterweise reden wir jetzt
darüber reiseverbote das ist gestern in
den raum gestellt worden dass sie prüfen
jetzt haben wir mal die gelegenheit
bevor eine solche entscheidung getroffen
worden ist hier zu sprechen ich sage
ihnen die haltung der fdp
ich rate ihnen von pauschalreisen
verboten ab setzen sie auf tests nicht
nur sind die preise verbote in
deutschland historisch belegt darüber
hinaus entsprechen sie wiederum nicht
der lebenswirklichkeit vieler familien
es gibt mildere mittel um das ziel der
pandemie bekämpfung zu erreichen und auf
der anderen seite ein neustart frau
merkel in der strategie bislang wurde
immer gesetzt auf das prinzip wir
bleiben zu hause mehr noch kann man
sagen der appell opfer zu bringen stand
im zentrum
es waren die mittel der central
verwaltungswirtschaft mit der die
pandemie gemanagt worden ist das ist
nicht nur fragwürdig verein ergebnissen
es ist auch eine gefahr weil das eine
einladung zur vetternwirtschaft sein
konnte
übrigens ich halte es für falsch wenn
die grünen pauschal von unions filz
sprechen
es stärkt nicht unsere politische kultur
wenn man individuelle verfehlungen zur
charakterfrage einer ganzen partei macht
das sollte man nicht tun aber umso mehr
ist es jetzt erforderlich auch innerhalb
der bundesregierung zu fragen was
eigentlich aus den einflussnahmen
geworden ist ich habe keinen zweifel
daran dass sie alles mit rechten dingen
zugegangen ist
es wäre aber sinnvoll frau
bundeskanzlerin wenn sie durch ein
sonderermittler mit richterlicher
unabhängigkeit der akten einsehen kann
für die öffentlichkeit transparenz
machen das im bundesministerium für
gesundheit bei den beschaffungsprozessen
alles mit rechten dingen zugegangen ist
wir brauchen daraufhin
ja genau es eine andere pandemie politik
auch in der strategie weg von bleiben zu
hause von der central
verwaltungswirtschaft hin zu vertrauen
und zu marktwirtschaftlichen lösungen
was heißt das das heißt was heißt das es
heißt vertrauen darauf dass handel
gastronomie tourismus hotellerie kultur
und sport wirksame hygiene konzepte
entwickelt haben die sie im eigenen
interesse achten und umsetzen wollen
vertrauen wir also den betrieben dass
sie in der lage sind ihre kundinnen und
kunden zu schützen machen wir das
vorliegen eines schnelltests zur
voraussetzung dafür am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilzunehmen
und frau bundeskanzlerin ich sage ihnen
wenn für die menschen mit einem
schnelltest verbunden ist dass sie zb
wieder an kulturellen veranstaltungen
teilnehmen können dann wird ohne
staatliche lenkung einfach aus der
gesellschaftlichen mitte mit
erfindergeist hinaus mehr test kapazität
geschaffen
vertrauen wir stark auf die kommunale
ebene
wenn der landkreistag das ist ja jetzt
nicht eine oppositionspartei wenn der
landkreistag ebenfalls einen neustart
fordert weg von dem instanz werten und
mehr regionale differenzierung fordert
ist das doch richtig in bayern muss
jedes modell vorhaben von der csu
staatsregierung genehmigt werden da ist
gar nicht die regionale eigenen
verantwortung stark alles muss zentral
aus münchen genehmigt werden also
stärken wir die kommunen und nicht
zuletzt kommen wir bitte zu mehr
pragmatismus beim im prozess und zwar
jetzt hausärztin fachärzte auch in
großem umfang ich verstehe das
eigeninteresse der öffentlichen hand an
den impfzentren wir können aber mehr
tempo aufnehmen wenn wir mit
pragmatismus die praktikerinnen und
praktiker in diesem prozess einbeziehen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie spreche heute
den amerikanischen präsidenten im format
des europäischen rates
ich schlage vor dass sie das angebot
unterbreiten zu einem speziellen e usa
impfgipfel zusammenzukommen die
vereinigten staaten haben impfdosen die
sie selbst im inland nicht verwenden
hier besteht die möglichkeit der
kooperation das ist besser als über
exportverbote in der europäischen union
nachzudenken und vor allen dingen soll
sie kann und muss mit den vereinigten
staaten darüber gesprochen werden wie
beide usa und europäische union der
geostrategischen ins politik russlands
und chinas mit blick auf die
schwellenländer auf den afrikanischen
kontinent eine antwort geben
wir sollten das china und russland nicht
allein überlassen
mein letzter gedanke zunächst generation
york mit ihrer erlaubnis herr präsident
ich bringe es auf einem kurzen punkt es
kostet nicht viel mühe gründe zu finden
warum am next schöne wäsche jung und der
eu wieder aufbau von geht's nicht
zustimmen wollte konjunktiv
beispielsweise die unterschätzung des
binnenmarktes da bräuchten wir impulse
wir können nicht nur im format der
staatlichen investitionen und der
öffentlichen ausgaben denken wenn wir
wachstum wollen er wäre im binnenmarkt
mehr möglich gewesen aber dennoch ist
ein guter schritt in der pandemie
zusammenzuhalten
in der im letzten jahr haben die sohlen
sparsamen vier auch veränderungen
herbeigeführt konditionalität der mittel
auszahlung
die sparsamen vier haben erreicht dass
das europäische semester also
reformvorhaben mitgedacht werden
beim auszahlen ich habe im juli des
letzten jahres aufgrund der politischen
freundschaft zurückgeschrieben mark
rutte sei der eigentliche nachfolger von
wolfgang schäuble
mir ist schon klar dass im
regierungshandeln die bundesrepublik
deutschland im sinne einer dienenden
führungsrolle nicht an die seite nur der
fuge vorgehen kann
aber so einseitig wie sich ihre
regierung den vertretern mediterraner
finanzpolitik genähert haben sollte dass
zukünftig nicht herr kollege leben und
deshalb deshalb herr präsident mein
letzter satz ich persönlich werde
zustimmen aber aus anderen gründen als
herr scholz alles was herr scholz rühmt
die europäischen wiederaufbau form
gemeinsame schulden und gemeinsame
um steuern wollen wir in der zukunft
politisch verändern und das passiert in
den nächsten jahren vielen dank
[Applaus]